everything has a kind of rhythm and when
you have a piece that has many parts you
have many rhythms within that piece
musicians inspire me a lot dance
inspires me because all of this is about
movement and gesture I imagine a piece
but connected with the imagining of the
piece is very much the feeling of the
piece so to be really honest I would say
it happens both in my mind and my heart
because it's connected you know on a
human level for example Korres yellow
chair the first imagination I had was I
looked at my son's yellow chair in the
studio and I saw it explode into 12
what I was seeing in my mind were pieces
that would explode instantaneously with
infinite speed instantaneously flying
out to the far reaches of the universe
where they would slowly slow down and
then gradually get pulled back together
with this gravitational field or
infinite speed and instantaneous motion
is not possible as a visible world but
all along the way there's a
communication between the real world and
my imaginary world and it's evolving
together the piece over here machine
with abandoned doll that was inspired
one moment when I found that abandoned
doll on the side of the road off of
highway 1 in California and I had
stopped to look at the ocean and I
noticed this abandoned doll at a trashy
I picked it up and it really spoke to me
when I was in college I did a lot of
puppetry and the whole world of puppetry
is one of the foundational art forms
that's behind what I do in terms of
thinking about objects as theater but
the law is a law is if it moves it'll
break it's just a matter of time I've
thought about this a lot because I've
always thought about there's a graph
right of my available time here and and
then the amount of pieces in the world
and at some point they cross right legal
like this where were the more pieces in
the world the less time I have because
I'm sniffing all night I'm fixing them
yeah there's a logical point where I
wouldn't be able to make any more work I
just have to be fixing everything
Corey's yellow chair when I first built
it it there were some components in
there that were very different than what
they are now and those are evolving and
changing so I do have the impulse to
want to make it better and to make it
last forever even though I know it won't
but still it's an interesting challenge
and it's and it's a viable thing to do
as a as an engine
and as an artist but I accept that at
some point all the pieces will will be
non-functional at some point they'll be
non-functional but by the same token we
only have another billion years on the
planet anyway before the Sun has
expanded the point where life is not
supported so I mean from up from a time
point of view if there's no time it
doesn't really matter in the end I mean
it it doesn't really matter